how do you think the return back to an
office is going to affect that because
i've seen a lot of employers asking
their employees to come back and there
is a difference in working remotely in
something in person in what way in a way
where i think in terms of creativity um
i think there's there's a there's a hive
mindset that happens when you get people
together in a room that you just can't
recreate online or over zoom so you're
more for working in office than working
from home
oh yeah i mean there's and there's no
question about it it's like saying
taking a girl out on a dinner uh and you
say hey uh
mary love to take you out on dinner i'm
gonna have ubereats deliver and i'm
gonna send you a nice bottle of wine you
have it over there but let's do it on
zoom and i'm gonna order the same thing
here and i'm just gonna look at you
through the camera you're so beautiful
babe can you give me your hand let me
give you your hand here through zoom and
let me do this what are we talking about
right i mean
again
this this and by the way here's what's
crazy about it watch this the same
people
that said
working remote
that's what we should do
you know what states they were
california
new york right d.c
illinois who were all for working remote
and then what happened when it backfired
on all these politicians
people said let me get this straight
you mean to tell me i can make 120 and i
can leave chicago and go to nashville i
can leave new york go to miami he's
still going to pay me 120. i can leave
california and go to nevada you're still
going to pay me to 120.
you know what i support remote you're
right except i'm remotely leaving your
state
so the concept of working remote
backfired
on the people that shut down states
cities and supported it you're seeing a
lot of entrepreneurs nowadays look what
goldman just did so goldman originally
solomon is like you guys got to come
back nobody's coming back you guys got
to come back nobody's coming back
solomon just announced a month ago guess
what what quarterly reviews and annual
reviews are back why we can officially
document that your performance is bad
and we can fire you because before we
couldn't fire you because what if you
come back and you see xyz nope we're
bringing it back what's facebook saying
what's google saying what's everybody
else saying either come back and improve
your performance or you're fired mo
zuckerberg just said if you don't
improve your performance you're fired
what's going on with the market amazon
180 this year so far so what happened
there this this remote thing is a great
idea
and it's solid but it's not effective
one of the best ways to gauge whether
companies are still using zoom or not is
through the stock
it's very simple
four years ago
pre-pandemic
stock of zoom was seventy dollars
you know what it peaked at you remember
what happened yeah
yeah that's crazy yeah it went from 70
bucks to 500 500 600 700 some dollar
amount like that you know where it's at
today 100 yeah
so what does that mean if zoom went from
70 to 56 700 down to 120 what's it
saying what percentage is 70 on 120
yeah it grew how much in the last three
four years
so companies are no longer using zoom as
much as they did a year ago or year and
a half ago and they're going away from
it so do you think though that's going
to bring a lot more people back to those
states i worry that people maybe have
gotten a little bit too confident that
they could take a remote job
work in another state where right now i
would not be surprised if companies
begin laying off people and they say hey
if you don't show up you don't have a
job everyone says well the job market is
good now but i think a year from now it
might not be the case and people might
say well no no actually i'll go back nah
you're right i mean look data came out
today do you know
a 0.26 .26
of all homes in illinois right now are
in foreclosure is it uh one in 385
that's the highest in america
0.26 now somebody may say well that's
not a big number
one in 385 homes in illinois right now
is in foreclosures the highest in
america today we haven't started that
yet obviously we're going to see what's
going to happen because at 300 percent
well last year when they were doing the
forgiveness and you know more banks
right now are saying don't worry about
it don't worry about making a payment
don't worry about making a payment
there's plenty of equity plenty of
equity eventually they're going to say
listen man you got to make a payment
okay this loan modification concept is
only there's a timeline too where you
eventually make a payment that's going
to happen
companies are going to go back realizing
i can't create a culture on zoom i can
only create culture on face-to-face you
know they're gonna try to sell it to
their management and their management
some of them that fight it will be fired
and they'll go and take a nice severance
for three or six months and then they're
gonna have to go find a job that's gonna
ask them to work
face to face live and they're gonna say
i don't have any other choice you know
what i should have stayed at that last
company because the benefits was better
that is going to come that movement will
take place
but if you lost those people to another
state and they realize another state
cost of living is lower they're probably
not coming back to your state if you
enjoyed this video i give a keynote a
few weeks ago in las vegas specifically
on the topic of cracking a code to
content creation if you've not seen it
click here to watch it take care
everybody bye
[Music]